cars have started flying on the roads in
serene other the capital of
indian-administered Kashmir but
commercial vehicles have not both paid
phone connections have been restored but
the internet is still cut off shops have
reopened but only for a few hours almost
three months after the Indian government
stripped indian-administered Kashmir of
its autonomy and imposed severe
restrictions
some have been eased but the people of
Kashmir Valley are in limbo they are
caught between the Indian Army and the
rebels between the need to register
their protest and to earn for survival
sixteen-year-old navi --the khan a class
10 student is doing last-minute
preparations for his Social Sciences
exam even when the school officially
reopened his parents thought it was
unsafe for him to return they feared
clashes between the Indian Army and the
rebels and worried about him getting
caught in the middle children and boys
pelted stones my parents were afraid I
may get caught in the protests so they
didn't send me to school a shopkeeper
and a father of two says he is forced to
open his shop in the mornings but he
keeps it shut the rest of the day to
protest New Delhi's decision he opened
the shop because it is our livelihood
because we have to support our family
but I shut it down now in protest to
abrogation of article 370 businesses
across the Kashmir Valley are following
a self-imposed strike the people hope
that one day the world may take notice
of their silent protest they could not
organize like previous times because
anyone who could lead was apprehended by
the Indian government the incidents of
attacks on security officials are on a
rise in recent attacks
officials said five truckers and five
laborers from India were gunned down by
suspected rebels theories hope their
resistance will yield results eventually
the Indian government is hoping to tire
them out in a battle of wills few
believe this Indian government will give
in for crush miri protesters in 10 and
20
their opposition they save just because
they're taking their kids to school or
going to work does not mean they have
accepted New Delhi's decision algebra al
Jazeera Srinagar indian-administered
Kashmir